- All I have to say it this.
(distinctive rubbing)
(whipping noise)
(playful music)
My relationship with my body hair is
a interesting saga.
- I remember being in the pre-school
and kids making fun of me,
calling me a werewolf.
- I went through puberty
a little bit earlier
than most people.
I swam in t-shirts.
I wore sweat pants to P.E. everyday.
If I was taking a shower at home
I didn't even want my family seeing.
- I've never shaved my
body hair, this much.
- I hope that I can carry,
what I've learned about myself
and accepting who I am.
- You know what, I'm a confidant man.
I think I could pull off hairy or smooth.
(pensive music)
- I think this is going to
definitely be one to remember.
- Personally, I probably
haven't shaved my legs in
six months.
- [Ryan] Oh my God.
- I know how to shave.
- Let's do this.
(racing music)
- [Caitlin] I think there is
a drastic amount of work.
- [Kirsten] Women are
suppose to have smooth legs.
Smooth arms, hairless arm pits.
(racing music)
- [Caitlin] I know a
double standard for a man,
to giving a woman shaving.
- [Kirsten] The third day I think
is gonna be most interesting.
- My skin color is so weird.
I've never seen it without hair like this.
- They definitely missed some spots.
Yeah, like, that's...
That's there.
- [Woman] How many times
you touch your arms today?
- So many.
There's so naked.
Tuesday, when my leg hair started growing,
I couldn't sleep.
(ominous music)
it's 3 AM.
I'm so itchy.
I don't want to be smooth anymore.
- I loved rubbing my legs together.
I am doing this for the rest of the night.
(distinctive rubbing)
So I just got back from
a work out class.
I feel like I could go faster.
I don't know if that
was just in my head but,
science-wise,
it should be correct.
(dramatic music)
- I miss my arm hair.
I miss my leg hair.
- I know I can get ready in 15 minutes
and be out the door.
I just showered.
Now going to do my final shaving.
I mean that will double, triple the time
of your shower.
- Shaving has been an
experience, to say the least.
- My favorite part about it
was right after you
shave for the first time.
I love how it feels.
It's like, so soft.
- It was weird 'cause I
was getting some looks.
'Cause my arm hair, it's not
fully grown back yet
and it's not super smooth.
- A lot of people actually didn't notice
that I had done anything until
I would point it out to them.
They're pretty supportive.
People like it actually.
They said it made my arms look skinnier
and my calves more defined.
- I don't know why society puts
such a pressure on body hair.
- I can't imagine having
to do this all the time.
At the end of the day, if
you don't want to do it,
you shouldn't have to.
It should be your own personal choice.
- [James] It's what's on
the inside that counts
whether you're hairy or smooth,
you can be masculine or not.
Being a hairy guy, I say,
grow with the flow.
(upbeat music)
(whizzing noise)